foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the dragon video in this video
I want to have a look at the new
interview with Amelia who I know all of
you remember as the legendary Mother of
Dragons Daenerys Targaryen from Game of
Thrones in her new interview she
discusses many different things I know
you'll find very interesting I'm sure
many of you have been wondering if
Familia has been watching HBO's new Game
of Thrones series House of the dragon as
someone who will always be seen as the
most beloved member of House Targaryen I
know there's many fans who have to be
wondering how she feels about this new
show that's focusing on the family she
helped bring to life so wonderfully in
the original show first I will show you
what she said about watching House of
the Dragon unfortunately the audio isn't
very good in the video so I'll show you
what she said then I'll say it again
just in case some of you weren't able to
hear it
foreign
[Music]
all right so as you can see Amelia said
she wanted to wait until all the
episodes have been released before she
begins watching the show Game of Thrones
veteran director and House of the Dragon
showrunner Miguel is one of her dear
friends now since they're friends and
Miguel is helping make the show Amelia
feels she must watch it out of love for
him not that she wouldn't watch it
anyway I'm sure she's dying to know
what's happening and how so the dragon
although I'm sure it would also be hard
to watch considering how this show and
its characters are so near to her heart
I'm guessing her watching the show would
be like riding one hell of an emotional
roller coaster she ends it by saying she
is sure will be amazing because it does
look incredible based on what she's seen
so far now there was another very
interesting thing she said that I wasn't
able to find in the video however I did
notice there were several articles
written about it since this interview
was released it must be in another video
I haven't been able to find another
thing she mentioned was how she actually
feels about daenerys's ending in the
Game of Thrones finale as you can see in
this headline it says Game of Thrones
star Amelia doesn't think Daenerys
deserved her fate she said I'm on her
side one of the most divisive aspects of
the final season of Game of Thrones was
the death of fan favorite character
Daenerys Targaryen and Amelia has now
addressed her fate let's be honest this
is something I have been saying for many
years now all of us knew deep down
Amelia did not like how Daenerys went
out in the show if it wasn't already
obvious in her interviews after she was
done filming her scenes or if it wasn't
obvious when they did the table read
during the Game of Thrones documentary
then let it be known now Amelia did not
like how the Game of Thrones writers did
the Mother of Dragons dirty in the end
we see Jon with his hands still on the
hilt of the dagger he just lodged in
Danny's heart
her strength leaves her and she
collapses to the marble
with how things ended yeah
she didn't say yes
best season ever
Amelia also said I still think Daenerys
did nothing wrong it's not fair that Jon
gets to live now what is also very
interesting is what she says next Amelia
goes on to say I want Daenerys with him
with John they could go to family
therapy and fix their issues Daenerys is
a very hopeful character she has a lot
of hopes and I wish that she was able to
achieve that I find this very
interesting because as you all know it
was Jon Snow who murdered Daenerys in
the Game of Thrones finale it just goes
to show you how much Amelia believed in
daenerys's love for Jon she wanted them
to live happily ever after well at least
as happy as you could be in the Game of
Thrones Universe this article also says
although Daenerys certainly appeared to
be dead as a doornail we have seen
characters resurrected in the HBO show
is there any way Daenerys could show up
in the new Jon Snow series HBO is
developing the secret Invasion star
admitted that it's highly unlikely but
she did add Never Say Never now this
sounds very different from what she said
in our last interview about the Jon Snow
show in the last interview Amelia said
she thinks she's done with the Game of
Thrones universe but now she's saying
never say never which means she's now
open to the idea for those of you who
might not know already Mr Harrington who
was the actor for Jon Snow and HBO are
in the works of developing a Jon Snow
show that focuses on his life and
Adventures after the Game of Thrones
season 8. this has been confirmed not
only by Amelia herself but George RR
Martin on his NADA blog as well if you
have been watching my videos then you
know I've been saying this would happen
also I have been saying over and over
again that many other Game of Thrones
actors will eventually want to come back
to Westeros once they realize how much
they actually miss working on the most
successful show in history it's only a
matter of time before we hear all of the
living actors say they would be willing
to come back to Westeros again obviously
the Jon Snow actor is making his own
show his friend from Game of Thrones
Samwell said he would also be open to
the idea even Brienne said she would
love to come back to the Game of Thrones
universe and Maisie Williams who
everyone knows as Arya Stark said the
same thing almost all of the main
characters who were alive at the end of
Game of Thrones said they would work
with HBO again so this opens the door
for so many other show ideas now let me
show you what Amelia also said about the
Jon Snow show what she said makes me
think she's seen some of the videos
about it you'll see what I mean
I mean it's just difficult because
spoiler generous dies
[Applause]
[Music]
as you can see she at first says it
would be difficult because Daenerys died
in the end but then she does start
thinking about how it could be fixed she
jokingly said maybe she could show up as
a white walker then she said a little
more seriously you never know we don't
know where her body is at maybe drogon
could help her out well this is exactly
what many of us have already been
thinking many fans believe and hope
drugon will fly her over to volantis
where canvara is located in hopes of her
resurrecting the Mother of Dragons by
way of the Lord of Light this is
certainly one way we could see Daenerys
in the new Jon Snow series after the
massive success of HBO's new Showhouse
of the Dragon I'm sure they're thinking
of ways they could revive Game of
Thrones in some way the fact that
they're even developing a series
centered around Jon Snow lets us know
they're interested and open to the idea
of resurrecting Game of Thrones as a
whole I think as soon as the first
season of also the dragon is over we
will start to hear even more about the
development of this show Making Game of
Thrones again in some form or fashion
would be even more successful than House
of the Dragon there are millions of fans
who are ready to see the original show
get a better ending I just hope HBO
finds a way to get it done how many of
you think this is a bad idea and how
many of you would love the thought of
Jon or even Daenerys showing up in the
Game of Thrones Universe again whether
we actually like the idea or not I know
every single one of us would be watching
either way so leave me some of your
thoughts down below as always I want to
thank all of you for watching this video
I hope all of you have a great day I
will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
foreign